so what I want to do here is continue
our discussion on Secret Wars with the
last and final issue something I also
want to point out here is that if you're
looking to get into the main Secret Wars
series including the lead-up to
everything that got us here I have a
playlist that you can find in the
description of this video
having said that where issue 7 & 8 saw
the coming together of various armies
across the battle world some of which
were designed to overthrow Doom and
replace him where others just wanted
freedom at the conclusion of issue
number 8
why Panther made his appearance
alongside name of the Submariner
brandishing the Infinity Gauntlet and
leading a full contingent of Marvel
Zombies and so picking up with issue
number 9 we continue the confrontation
between two charlet and dr. doom now
what's interesting about this is that
initially Doom attributes' the surge of
arby's rising against him as the work of
T'Challa but as we discussed in one of
our previous videos this was actually
orchestrated by the combined efforts of
both versions of Reed Richards from the
earth-616 and Ultimate Universe
respectively with Maximus the mad
operating as the figure who could rally
these armies together allowing for both
versions of Reed to operate from the
shadows in addition to this doom
actually tries to sway them to his side
by appealing to their roles as Kings
what I mean here is that prior to the
events of time lines out which saw Namor
into tralala waging war against one
another resulting in their kingdoms
instructions Namor ruled over Atlantis
and two-child ruled over Wakanda with
each individual dealing with their own
burdens and that the outside world was
constantly attempting to attain
wakanda's vibranium stores while
simultaneously encroaching on the ocean
territories of Namor however T'Challa
and Namor ultimately reject the olive
branch offered by doom and using the
Infinity Gauntlet ability to control all
things turned doomed a glass with the
intention of killing him now something
to point out here is that what we're
seeing at the moment is actually
something we've never seen before what I
mean here is that historically the
Infinity Gauntlet has been used by
various individuals in the past but
never against someone wielding the power
of the beyonders because the beyonders
were capable of eliminating the cosmic
entities up to and including the Living
Tribunal the question being asked here
is this is doomed truly using the full
power of the beyonders the reason why I
asked this question is that during the
events of infinity war at least assuming
that had been considered it to be
official material the Living Tribunal
had rebuked Adam warlock claim regarding
the
incredible power by quite literally
keeping him from being able to use it
temporarily and so using the transitive
property we can argue that if the
beyonders have the power to destroy a
living tribunal and the living tribunal
had the power to quell the Infinity
Gauntlet then it stands to reason that
the beyonders are more powerful than the
Infinity Gauntlet however the issue that
we face here is that there don't
actually seem to be any beyonders left
in the last vestiges of the power rests
in the hands of doom by way of molecule
man and where victor is able to
reconstitute himself after numerous
attack he greets T'Challa as an enemy
with a - doing battle meaning that
unless we're provided a definitive
answer at this part of the story we
don't know which one of the two is
stronger from here hickman switches our
focus to both versions of Reed meeting
Susan storm and valaria now this is of
stupendous importance in that this is
the first time Reed and Susan have met
since the collapse of the multiverse and
her presumed death where our previous
videos established that Reed had become
aware that Susan was alive and operating
under the control of Victor Hickman's
portrayal of Reed and the inherent issue
of his character during the events of
future foundation are carried over to
his reuniting with Susan what I mean
here is that during Hickman's run a
fantastic for the plot of the story
revolved around Reed's disconnect with
his family and the face of his love for
science technology and solving the
world's problems were the conclusion of
future foundation and the arrival of
Franklin from the future solve this
problem by illustrating the need for
Reed to exist as a family man the lack
of affection towards Susan as is
displayed here coupled with the anger he
clearly shows towards new manipulations
of Susan's mind tells us that Reed still
cares for his family but in this
instance stopping doom stripping him of
his power and turning things to the way
they were is of the utmost importance to
this end when the question is asked by
Susan as to who Reed truly is rather
than revealing himself as her husband he
simply states that he's there to fix
things now this point we follow both
versions of Reed into the secret lair of
dr. doom which is designed to house a
contained molecule man now we're
ultimately was originally brought to us
as a villain over the course of his
publications in the Ultimate Universe
when the collapse of the multiverse
occurred he survived and encountered the
main Marvel Reed Hickman played a bit of
deception and that were ultimately still
demonstrated patterns of villainy it was
believed at least by me anyway that the
villainous nature of his character had
taken a backseat
the necessity of destroying doom however
this proves not to be the case in that
when both versions of Reid encounter
molecule man ultimate Reid traps the
main Marvel Reid and a bubble of time in
addition to this what we're told is that
because of the nature of battle world
time was believed to flow forward only
with the inability to flow backwards
meaning the time travel to the past was
impossible the reason for this was due
to the fact the battle would was created
with the power of the beyonders and his
beings who only existed linearly meaning
they could only move forward in time the
belief was at battleworld function in
the same way now to be honest here I
would argue that this was the moment
when Marvel deviated away from the idea
of rebooting their continuity and chose
to keep it the same but this is
something that we'll discuss later in
the story for now the actions of
ultimate Reed trapping his counterpart
in a sphere of time causing him to
travel backwards and forwards is rooted
in the idea that ultimate Reed intends
to eliminate his counterpart or at the
very least immobilize them entirely
however during the taunts Owen Reese
steps in by rematerializing ultimate
Reed into food but he can actually
consume effectively removing him from
the picture now the reason for why
molecule man chose to intervene isn't
really explained here with the exception
of a warning to the last remaining Reed
that Victor Von Doom is coming but I
would argue that this is really just a
Winry satisfying his hunger due to the
vast amount of power he possesses and in
doing so elected to kill the villain
rather than the hero a regardless
shifted this way back to doom
temporarily we learn that the power of
the beyonders is indeed greater than the
gauntlet and that doom is essentially
beating in toiling with T'Challa
however despite all his vaunted power
and knowledge it's not until two chala
begins to taught doom that Victor
realizes that the chala went into the
conflict knowing it was impossible for
him to win and that all of the events
that have transpired from the first
battle at Castle doom up until the
current moment have all been a ruse
designed to allow both versions of Reed
the opportunity to locate Doom source of
power and attempt to destroy it now
traveling to Owen in an effort to stop
Reed from whatever his mecha Nations
happen to be in my opinion this portion
of the story provides us with one of the
best do monologues in the history of
Marvel Comics what we're told is that
were previously Dumais considered
himself to be more capable than Reed
based simply on their knowledge of
science and technology or willingness to
do what needed to be done at the moment
Jim considers himself to be a better man
due to his actions at the
hustle of the multiverses collapse
because dooms strange and Owen Reese
stood at the brink of the multiverses
destruction face the beyonders overcame
them and took their power doom used the
opportunity to create battle world and
in doing so saved millions of beings
from the fragments of alternate
realities that hadn't yet been
completely destroyed as a result because
Reed was only able to save himself and a
handful of others dooms taunts amount to
calling Reed a coward in a failure due
to his inability to save his own family
now were doom attempts to kill Reed
using his vast powers the true nature of
Owen Reese comes into play and that
rather than operating simply as a source
of dooms power Reese's more akin to a
gatekeeper holding the keys and allowing
doom to use the power of the beyonders
this particular bit comes to light when
Owen bestows Reed with the power equal
to doom allowing the two to engage in a
grudge fight of sorts now the battle
between Reed and doom as it's written
here is absolutely amazing and that
Hickman is giving us an instance where
every ounce of frustration and anger is
being laid bare from the perspective of
doom despite the various powers he's
gained over the years and the struggles
that he's endured his life has never
been an easy one to sidetrack for a
second this is actually Hickman paying
homage to dooms attempts to save his
mother's soul from the Fisto with his
various schemes over the years designed
to acquire the power to do so as a
result dooms anger towards Reed and
stopping his conquests over the years
isn't rooted in the fact that he was
defeated so much as it was rooted in the
fact that Reed has essentially been
stopping doom from saving his mother on
the other hand Reed's anger towards doom
is much simpler in that when the
multiverse collapsed rather than saving
Susan Franklinville area and been
keeping them whole and waiting for Reed
once he arrived instead doom attempted
to take his place by stripping Reed's
family of their knowledge of him and
acting as Reed himself having said that
the battle between the two comes to a
head when du makes the argument that
Reed believes he's a better person and
that have granted the power of the
beyonders he would have made a better
world rather than creating one of
conflict and turmoil furthermore when
Reed forces doom to admit that this is
true following this statement I win
Reese makes the case that if both Doom
and Reed agree that Reed would have made
a better world then the opportunity will
be granted for Reed to prove it and so
using his power to effectively wipe the
slate clean as battleworld and all
things with n are completely eliminated
T'Challa seizes the time gem of the
infinite
and a last bid to save himself from here
things get a little hairy but they get
really interesting at the same time and
that we actually jump back to when the
incursians first began with a retelling
of Avengers vol 3 is your number 1 what
this tells us is that while it's not
shown Reid seems to have somehow either
stopped the incursions from happening or
else change the outcome and that
T'Challa has successfully traveled to
the Past where the time Jim being
destroyed once he arrived in addition to
this where the beginning of the
incursions open with Black Panther
witnessing and in cursive earth
preparing to crash into the main Marvel
Universe followed by the appearance of
Black Swan all actions of T'Challa and
his tribesmen appear to be the same here
with the exception of the fact that
rather than witnessing an incursion take
place they witness the launching of a
vessel into space for the purpose of
exploration from here we jump to Miles
Morales and Peter Parker where miles has
a flashback to Owen thanking him for
bringing a hamburger what this tells us
is that Miles Morales still remembers
everything that had taken place during
the events of secret Wars on battle
world where Owen had responded to miles
by stating that he owes m1 his favor
seems to have come to fruition with
Miles being thrown into the same
universe as Peter allowing for miles to
fight alongside his hero against various
villains and so as a story begins to
come to a close Hickman brings a
conclusion of secret Wars into full view
by telling us how things have changed
and setting the stage for the direction
of the future of Marvel Comics what
we're told is that the incursions the
destruction of the multiverse and the
death of the cosmic entities all took
place meaning that as of this moment
with the exception of Galactus in The
Ultimates there don't seem to be any
cosmic entities in the all-new
all-different marvel universe in
addition to this where the beyonders
were essentially defeated by Doctor
Strange Doctor Doom and Owen Reese
rather than doom using the power of the
beyonders to create battle world the
process of recreating all things fell to
Reed Franklin and Owen Reese with the
explanation coming to susan by way of
Valyria Owen Reese exists as a battery
of sorts and that he's a source of the
beyonders power and the ability to
create things at the same time Franklin
is both a universal and multiversal
constant meaning that he's able to tap
into the power of Owen Reese and use it
to create universes finally with Reed's
vast intellect and experience the
abilities of Owen and Franklin are
combined allowing for Reed to instruct
Franklin
on how to engineer universes and send
them off into the multiverse to function
and grow on their own and so what
Hickman is essentially telling us is
that where Reid is viewed as the savior
of the multiverse to the battleworld
having never happened and all-new
all-different marvel the reason why Reid
Susanville area and Franklin aren't
present and any existing stories is due
to the fact that they're quite literally
engineering universes to recreate the
multiverse with each reality containing
its own molecule man now in truth this
is really just an opportunity for Marvel
to shut the Fantastic Four out of the
landscape and keep them out of stories
similar what was done with Nick Fury
during original sin this is evident in
the fact that when Franklin asks if
they're superheroes anymore Reid
responds by saying that their work won't
stop it's simply creating universes and
that all of these alternate realities
have to be catalogued monitored and
maintained until they go to the point of
becoming self-sustaining after which
time the Fantastic Four will return
furthermore in the closing pages of this
story is revealed that throughout his
entire ordeal from the start of the
incursions his journey to find his
family his battle with Doom and Owen
Reese resetting the events after the
multiversal collapse allowing for the
recreation of all things Reid himself
had to learn multiple lessons and that
the failure of Doom was his desire to
hold on to everything he had for fear of
losing it and that this fear was
ultimately as downfall and that he was
essentially a man holding his life in
his hands with no foundation but as soon
as the things that doom loved were taken
away from him he was essentially a
broken man using this as a platform Reid
intends to use the time engineering
universes to connect with his family
connect with what it means to live and
rather than holding on so tight to the
things he loves simply allow the
universe to grow and function as it
should
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know down in the comment section what
you guys think about secret war so far
and be sure to check that link in the
description if you want to watch the
whole thing even waiting all this time
for me to finally get the last video out
and now you want to binge watch it which
I'm not against I'd be awesome but let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace